في العراق وصلت البطاله نسب قياسيه العمل
الماضي سته عشر فاصله خمسه في المئه نسبه
العاطلين عن العمل وفق وزاره التخطيط
استنادا الى اخر مسح نفده الجهاز المركزي
للاحصاء بالتعاون مع منظمه العمل الدوليه
اي نحو مليونين من اصل 42 مليون هم سكان
العراق
ويفاقم تزايد اعداد خريج الجامعات الذين
لم يتمكنوا من الحصول على وظائف يفاقم عدم
الاستقرار الامني والسياسي والاقتصادي
الشباب العراقي العاطل عن العمل يواصل
احتجاجاته في محافظات عده وفي مقر الشركات
النفطيه في الجنوب رغم تعهد الحكومه
بالعمل للحد من البطاله والفقر
بحسب ارقام وزاره التخطيط العراقيه في مسح
اجرته بالتعاون مع منظمه العمل الدوليه
عام 2022
يتبين التالي نحو مليوني عاطلين عن العمل
في العراق سته وستون بالمئه بين بين
ثمانيه الى ثلاثه ثمانيه عشر الى 63 سنه
خارج سوق العمل اي 16 ونصف في المئه من
السكان
وثلاثه من هؤلاء يبحثون عن عمل
28.2% معدل البطاله بين الاناث وهو ضعف
معدل البطاله لدى الذكور ومعدل البطاله
لدى الشباب
35.8% اي اكثر بثلاثه اضعاف لدى البالغين
اما معدل البطاله اعلى في المناطق
الحضاريه منه من المناطق الريفيه حيث بلغ
17.6% وثلاثه عشر فاصله ثلاثه
في المئه على التوالي عدد الموظفين
الحكوميين والمتقاعدين بحدود سته ملايين
ونسبه الفقر في العراق تجاوزت قبل عامين
ثلاثه ثلاثين في المئه بسبب تداعيات جائحه
كورونا لكنها عادت مؤخرا الى 21% حسب
وزاره التخطيط العراقيه
الينا من بغداد مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
ابراهيم وليد بالنسبه لهذه الارقام نسال
عن انعكاساتها على
الشارع العراقي وعن الحلول ان كان هناك
حلول يجري تنفيذها من قبل وزاره التخطيط
العراقيه
الانعكاسات كبيره جدا على الواقع العراقي
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي حتى الاجتماعي
الارقام التي نتحدث عنها ارقام كبيره جدا
بحسب واحده من الارقام التي تمكنا من
الحصول عليها من اتحاد النقابات العمال
العراقيه يتحدث عن سته مليون عاطل عن
العمل هناك منظمات معنيه تتحدث عن ان
الرقم قد يزداد عن السته مليون الحلول هي
هذه المشكله الحلول حتى اللحظه هي غائبه
الكل يتحدث على انه لا حل لامتصاص او
لانهاء مساله البطاله في العراق الا
بتنشيط القطاع الخاص في العراق والقطاع
الخاص في العراق يكاد يكون غائب لا توجد
قوانين حقيقيه لانعاش هذا القطاع تحدث
الكثير من المعنيين في السنوات الماضيه
وقالوا انه لابد من وجود قوانين تنعش
القطاع الخاص واحده من هذه القوانين على
سبيل المثال هو قانون الضمان الاجتماعي
للعمال هذا القانون البرلمان العراقي في
دورته الماضيه لكنه لم يتم التصويت عليه
ووضع مره اخرى للمناقشه في دوره البرلمان
الحاليه وحتى اللحظه لم يتم التصويت عليه
الكثيرين يقولون كثيرون يقولون انه لا بد
من تفعيل قانون الضمان الاجتماعي للقطاع
الخاص لانه هو الوحيد الذي قادر على ان
يمتص هذا العدد الكبير من البطاله هذه
المشكله لا تقف عند الارقام التي تحدثنا
عنها قبل قليل هي مشكله متصاعده سوق العمل
سنويا يستقبل مئات الالاف من سواء من
الخريجين او من غير الخريجين على سبيل
المثال يوجد في العراق
اهليه وحكوميه 35 جامعه حكوميه و71 جامعه
اهليه تقول للارقام الصادره من وزاره
التعليم العالي ان الخريجين الذين يدخلون
سنويا الى سوق العمل يبلغ عددهم نحو 180
الف خريج هؤلاء من حمله شهادات بمختلف
التخصصات ومن بينهم ايضا طلبت دراسات عليا
من حمل شهاده الماجستير والدكتوراه نحن
نقف هنا على سبيل المثال في حي الكراده
هذا هذا المنظر الذي تشاهدوونه على
الكاميرا هذا هذا اصبح وسيله يلجا اليها
الشباب في عرض بضاعتهم على قارعه الطريق
من اجل الحصول على او هي فرصه عمل لكثير
من العاطلين على العمل الذين لم يتمكنوا
من الحصول على فرصه عمل سوى حكوميه او حتى
في القطاع الخاص كنت قبل دقائق اتحدث مع
احد الاشخاص هنا وكنت متفق مع ان يخرج
معنا ليتحدث لكنه في اللحظه الاخيره تراجع
واعتذر كان يحدثني ويقول انه يحمل شهاده
الكهرباء بكالوريوس في الكهرباء ولديه
ايضا شهادات اخرى معتمده من جهات غير
حكوميه يقول انه خريج منذ عام 2016 قدم
الى الكثير من مؤسسات الدوله ومن الشركات
الاهليه لكنه بالنهايه لم لم يستطع ان
يحصل على فرصه عمل وكان خياره الاخير او
بالاحرى لم يكن امامه من خيار بعد كل هذا
الا اللجوء الى قارعه الطريق لعرض بضاعته
على قارعه